rarely do we witness a fall from grace
so quick so complete that someone goes
from being beloved to a con man in the
eyes of the public overnight and from
the outside looking in it's strange
because every single thing that person
has ever said or done is suddenly cast
in a new much more Sinister light the
only comparison I can really think of is
Jared Fogle from Subway I mean all those
times he took his pants off and paraded
them in front of the children how did we
not see this as a sign it's like looking
at one of those white and gold dress
optical illusions suddenly you see it as
you know black and blue and you wonder
with this like sudden shift it's so
quick that you're like how did I ever
see it any differently and that's what
we're talking about today but with a
scam artist Alex machinski because he's
not in trouble for the same reasons
Jared Fogle was but he did screw over a
lot of people he shouldn't now you may
know Alex machinski because we've talked
about him on this program he's the
former CEO of Celsius and I'm not going
to cover everything he did because we we
already have talked about it extensively
however there's a lot of new news to
cover for one Alex machinski stepped
down as the CEO for two we found out
they owed billions of dollars more than
we thought they did three we know the
customer funds are still frozen but the
real new evidence coming out that in my
view takes Alex machinski from being a
slick salesman who you know basically
over promised to being a full-blown
Criminal Who should be in jail it just
recently happened although I need to
make a disclaimer that this is of course
my opinion that he's a criminal he has
not been formally charged although I
think a lot of you will share my view
once I get through explaining this
here's how it happened four days ago we
got a report from the financial times a
scoop that Alex machinski may have
withdrawn 10 million dollars off Celsius
ahead of freezing customer accounts and
ahead of the bankruptcy this obviously
would be very significant and very
suspicious but of course I wanted to
wait until this was confirmed by formal
bankruptcy documents and it was in
bankruptcy court Celsius was required to
disclose what their Executives did
leading up to bankruptcy and what we
found is that in the month of May the
month before they froze withdrawals and
declared bankruptcy Alex machinski and
other key Executives in Celsius withdrew
nearly 17 million dollars from this
platform Alex himself withdrew 10
million dollars of that Chrissy his wife
withdrew two million dollars remember
she's the one who said unbankrupt
yourself and sold shirts to that effect
which is a level of irony that I simply
do not have the time to unpack right now
but suffice to say other Executives also
withdrew another five million dollars
now okay why is this criminal why can't
they withdraw all this money from their
own platform well think about it
celsius's whole problem was that it was
suffering from a bank run too many
people were withdrawing too fast and
instead of acting as the captain going
down with the ship Alex machinski
instead basically did the analogy
equivalent of of jumping in a Lifeboat
but what's worse he actually did this
well deliberately lying to the people on
the boat and told them that everything's
fine in order to ensure his own safety
and ensure that he had a Lifeboat to
even get on because as the analogy goes
lifeboats were in short supply they
didn't have the money but let's dig
deeper than that because if we look at
the bankruptcy filings we can get an
entire history of Alex machinsky's
transactions which is important to prove
motive after all if he was always
withdrawing funds it wouldn't be
anything out of the ordinary but as you
can see on this fourth column which is
type incoming or outgoing from Celsius
machinski's pattern was that he only
really sent money to Celsius and did
keep most of his money there on platform
which is consistent through 2021 and
early 2022 until March 17th when
mashinski starts his first outgoing
withdrawals from the platform now at
first it's only a hundred thousand
dollars however this pattern drastically
changes once again in May after the Luna
crash when the markets are in turmoil
and Celsius realizes they're insolvent
now to understand the true scumbaggery
of this whole thing let me show you what
Alex was saying publicly before I show
you what he was doing privately and I
continued to huddle it's not like I've
changed my position I didn't sell my
Bitcoin I didn't sell my ethereum it's
not like one of us is smarter than
everybody else and they're sitting on
the sidelines while the rest of us are
taking a beating now look there is a lot
here to unpack from the phone number on
screen 1-866 hoddle now to his shirt
saying that banks are not your friends
uh to his incredibly strong claim that
he's not secretly sell it you know in
fact he's bi he's bullish right you
should be bullish to all of this to a
reasonable investor conveys the idea
that we're all in this together this is
some choppy water but we're gonna get
through it right don't head for the life
rafts it's fine there's no Iceberg ahead
now with that in mind I want you to now
look at what he was doing a day after
this on May 14th he was privately
withdrawing nearly all his crypto from
the platform 10 million dollars in
Bitcoin usdc and ethereum he jumped on
the Lifeboat and left this honestly
Border Lines on this Psychopathic are
sociopathic I do not know how you can
sit on stage and speak to a community of
your investors of your customers and
just dead lie to them and do the
opposite behind the scenes but maybe
some of you think well that was a day
later maybe he changed his mind just 24
hours later but there's actually proof
that no that's not true he was
deliberately lying because we're going
to look at what Alex said only a few
days after Jumping Ship right so we're
looking at before he jumped ship and
after this is from May 20th and it is
staggering uh keep thinking that okay we
we say one thing and we do something
else we're all we all still have most of
our coins right we didn't uh we didn't
sell we didn't bail out we didn't go and
look for another job we're in it for the
long term as Nook said we've done
several of these Winters
and we're still gonna be here in in in
several years from now I don't know what
to say I'm Blown Away Alex machinski is
saying in black and white that you know
we're not we're not saying one thing and
doing another uh we're we're doing
exactly what we want you to do we're
hodling right we're not bailing out even
though that's exactly what he actually
did this man is a master of lying
through his teeth and what this all
shows is that there is strong evidence
that Alex knew Celsius wasn't going to
be around in several years even though
he said he thought it was because if you
thought your company was going to be
around in seven years or several years
the last thing you would do is withdraw
because celsius's entire problem
remember is immediate liquidity they
didn't have enough money on hand so if
Alex truly thought and believed what he
said he did which is that it was going
to last several years the last thing you
would do is withdraw critical funds
exactly when you need them so this fact
that he was secretly withdrawing means
that he knew he was applying to
investors and the company was about to
go under for good and he was trying to
save himself I mean pretty sure he
didn't even call one eight six six
huddle now
uh okay that's bad joke but on a serious
note um this just made me so angry that
I decided I wanted to help and I wanted
to use these exact transactions and
transfers in order to try to correlate
them to on-chain transfers and figure
out where the money went in hopes that
we could maybe salvage some of it and
I'll tell you even though I was unable
to find Alex machinski's specific
wallets I do have some good news which
is that I found his wife Chrissy
machinski's wallets let me explain I
cross-referenced Chrissy machinski's May
31st withdrawal of 2.4 million Celsius
tokens against all of Celsius hot
wallets and found that on that day
there's only one similar transaction
within 10 Celsius tokens if you trace
where this went it goes to a wallet
which already is associated with Alex
machinski machinski literally funded it
with ethereum initially and this is
where 2.7 million dollars worth of
Celsius tokens went bear in mind it's
important this is only days before they
froze withdrawals showing that they
wanted to get money off platform and
although it hasn't been sold yet it can
be sold at any time and the reason I'm
sharing this wallet publicly is I want
to recommend that this is basically
claimed by the bankruptcy court or
seized because it's very likely that it
will be sold by the machinski's with
upcoming pressure increasing now I will
link this wallet in the description so
it can be publicly watched and tracked
by law enforcement or just anyone who's
interested I will also add the machinski
wallets that I've publicly labeled along
with several others I wish nothing but
the best for the victims out there if
you enjoy High effort investigations
like this please understand uh I put a
lot of my time into this so pumping the
stock is very much appreciated if you
want to catch up with the whole Celsius
Saga you can do so here but either way
thanks for watching and all the best to
all of you except for Alex and Chrissy
mashinsky